la acción de este lunes en la copa
africana de naciones en yaundé se
traslada al estadio amadou ajillo que
lleva el nombre del primer presidente de
camerún marruecos uno de los favoritos
se empieza a ver acción es uno de los
grandes candidatos al título sostenido
en varios jugadores que militan en el
fútbol europeo una defensa fuerte un
ataque temible pero lleva en sus
antecedentes el haber fallado en varias
ocasiones en los grandes escenarios y su
historia en todo caso en estos torneos
no lo acompaña tanto el antecedente más
cercano es la eliminación rápida de 2019
gana en su rival y es uno de los equipos
temibles por su historia no tanto por su
presente es cuatro veces ganador de la
copa africana de naciones y siempre es
un rival de cuidado también será el
estreno de la selección de comoras el
pequeño equipo del país isleño que
tendrá su primera participación
histórica en una copa africana de
naciones en frente de gabón el equipo
que tiene a pie de américa puede venían
y mario le mina como sus figuras hoy
ausentes por haberse contagiado de kobe
19 llega con varios problemas
institucionales y con justamente la
situación del o bien que han minado su
preparación para este torneo